welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode nine the series finale
a true gut punch of familial loss
overreaching fan theories and robots
talking boats
let's break down this finale scene by
scene frame by frame in some cases
to point out all those interesting
details that are a bit hard to catch
really folks going back to appreciate
the stuff they hide in these episodes
has always been my favorite part of this
i appreciate you folks for going on this
ride with me so here we go
you know we do get some nice fighting in
one division but none of it involved
realistic nuclear submarines though i
got a game that fills that void
conflict of nations is a free online pvp
strategy game where you choose a real
country to lead in modern global warfare
you fight up to 128 other players in
real time and use different units to
build your army including tanks
jets and yes even nuclear submarines i
really like that they got this world map
with
over 100 real territories that you can
invade i'm coming for you saskatchewan
i'm just kidding i'd like her friends up
there you can play with the same account
on both pc and mobile and for the next
30 days my viewers can click the link in
this description to get 13 000 gold in
one month of premium subscription for
free a special game was created for the
first viewers to click this link and i
will share details about that at the end
of the video
the previously on ends with wanda from
the end of last episode yellow frames
flickering over her if you pause it you
can see this is the moment the mind
stone showed her her future as the
scarlet witch the fully powered form she
becomes in this finale episode but
achieving this status comes with wanda
having to give up her family inside that
hex
but this episode tells us that family is
never truly lost
because our souls are rooted in the
memories that we share with loved ones
so
that way family can truly be forever
family is actually in the opening line
of this episode from tommy
brother my god this kid is being choked
and his main priority is the safety of
his brother
say it with me vin diesel family then
after creepily rising back up
agatha's purple blast now has a bit of
bread mixed in
showing how she stole some of wanda's
chaos magic and is throwing it back at
her wanda
cars agatha into the house with agatha's
empty boots sticking out like the wicked
witch of the east
with this witches basket bike hurling
fireballs from rooftops
red puffs of smoke and killing your
little dog too
agatha is very much the wizard of oz
inspired actually the 2013 film oz the
great and powerful shows up on the
marquee again
a film directed by sam raimi currently
directing elizabeth olsen as she returns
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness we're gonna explain how then
white vision floats
down is it really you similar to wanda's
confused greeting when she first meets
white vision in the comics but this mac
os vision doesn't play nice
that bone crunch sound effect luckily
vision knocks them into a winnebago and
boom
looking for a white vision walking right
out of those flames like the terminator
t-100 a true
killing machine now i love the camera
motion following wanda's glide up and
then back
through the window glass to monica
always appreciated how good this show is
about scene geography
like we always know where in west view
we are and when we don't know where we
are it's for a reason the action's very
easy to track i love it
now fietro traps monica in his man cave
using a super speed to tap her off her
feet
i love that ping an indicator that
monica herself is pretty sturdy
and even though fiatro is i guess not
fox x-men quicksilver
this man cave is super momentum these
are things we saw with quicksilver and
days of future past so you're just gonna
take the cool stuff about them but not
bring the character over
white vision goes right for that mind
stone ambition's head just like thanos
and the black order did
now at first in this fight between them
vision does have the edge by phase
shifting through white vision's blows
but notice how over the course of the
battle white vision learns from this
so that later in the library he catches
vision off guard
by the same kind of face shifting he's
learning i love the shot where white
vision rises from the crack pavement
trying to drag vision down
because white vision is essentially a
zombie corpse
from the grave dragon vision and angelic
form conceived in this afterlife
back down to hell now paul bettany is
pulling double duty as
both visions and this is confirmed this
was a big secret cameo that he teased
and they're gonna be so disappointed
when they find out it's me now i don't
mind this i think bethany's great in
both roles
but his trolling did kind of contribute
to a perfect storm of fan expectation
chaos something that we go into in
inside marvel go check that out now
hayward screen shows the comparative
vibranium decay of both visions notice
vision represented in gold has a higher
concentration than white vision
that's because white vision's vibranium
is older more decayed than his
hex counterpart whose vibranium was
manifested like weeks ago
jimmy wu snatches the phone in plain
sight of
this sword agent who i just assume just
hates hayward
you know hayward's a dick jimmy picks
the lock with flourish
another nod to his close-up magic
classes from ant-man and the wasp now
one of my greatest pleasures throughout
these breakdowns of one division is
pointing out just random background
extras in westview doing goofy npc [ __ ]
behind wanda is this dapper dan
frozen with his foot on the hydrant it's
not an easter egg i just love this
weirdo
he never moves mommy and then dennis the
mailman drives by in that presto truck
that
wasn't at all related to anything don't
shoot
i'm just a messenger now he said the
same thing back in episode two
don't shoot i'm just a messenger i'm
starting to think that dennis might just
be jimmy woo's missing witness
if you look closely in episode five he
was id'd on their id wall but we never
got a close look at what was written on
that file
the missing witness is definitely not
theatre slash ralph i will get to why
later but dennis just seems like he
could have been a past crook who would
cooperate with the feds to turn in his
past criminal associates
and then him saying don't shoot i'm just
a messenger is something you could
imagine
someone like that whimpering to like a
mafioso's gun in his face but then
agatha confirms that her spell book is
indeed the
darkhold marvel's book of the damned
this is potentially the biggest
confirmation of this episode see in the
comics the darkhold was a collection of
spells written by
and i think i got the right
pronunciation here shitan
the demon lord who originally cursed
wanda as a baby
agnes says here the scarlet witch is not
born she is forged she has no coven nor
need for incantation
forge likely refers to her forgery by
the mind stone because it was that
infinity stone application that made
wanda the scarlet witch
with nexus level powers unique among the
witches but ironically agaves says this
in front of a billboard for squeaky
shine using the power of mother earth
wanda's untaught magic is a natural
phenomenon whereas
agatha according to her latin bullying
moore's monstro naturai
she's a freak of nature and aberration
in nature she cheated via supernatural
means
and notice the book once again glows a
fiery orange color
the same color of magic that seemed to
protect agatha from the blue spells
and allowed her purple magic to take
over and drain the rest of the coven
presumably that magic came from the
darkhold and whatever demonic entity or
entities are contained within
now the dark gold is the source of all
supernatural horrors in the marvel world
like expect this book to come back in
multiverse of madness and blade
many believe it belongs among the other
spell books in the camera taj library
but
this looks way older like there is no
way librarian wong would let it get into
this shape i'm thinking this book
actually predates that entire library
it's far more dangerous than anything in
there but inside this book
these ancient runes and geometric
illustrations
notice that hexagon framing the scarlet
witch there
they do appear to link this magic of
agatha and her coven
to the marvel sorcerers she even
references doctor strange here your
power
exceeds that of the sorcerer supreme
it's your destiny to destroy
the world and by destroying the world i
think we can presume she means breaking
apart the universe into a multiverse of
alternate worlds
that might be what these various
overlapping circles on the opposite page
could be referring to now by the way
this is a very different dark hole than
the one in agents of shield or in
runaways
further telling us that those titles
might not be ensue cannon
though hey with the multiverse maybe one
day all this [ __ ] can be mcu cannon now
agave awakens meat puppet dottie whose
real name is sarah proctor
sarah proctor was the daughter of the
proctor family a family accused of
witchcraft during the salem witch trials
her father
john proctor was hanged now sarah's
husband is harold proctor aka jones
so presumably this is the name she
married into unless
harold took her name like i could see
him doing that he seems like a
progressive fella
now dottie sarah doesn't seem to also be
a witch in west view at least so far but
with agatha's survival this nosy
neighbor could identify another witch
with salem roots to try to mentor to
take under her wing
we just know witchcraft is an ongoing
thing in the mcu seven months later
in spider-man far from home with mr
dell's superstition came for science
we're leaving because of witches
welcome to the new dark ages so monica
realizes that
theatre is actually ralph the ralph
we've been looking for
the whole time the husband agatha can't
shut up about his name is ralph
boner look i'll have more thoughts on
why this whole evan peters casting
misdirect happened in the first place
there's actually probably a very good
reason for it we're going to talk about
an inside marble but for his part evan
peters had this to say about his cameo
dude i'm such a huge fan of the marvel
universe
it was so cool to come over there and
hang out with all those guys
as if this might not be an ongoing thing
going forward now the name boner could
be a nod to
agatha's oft-mentioned intimacy issues
with ralph or more likely and not do
growing pains mike seaver's buddy
richard steboon
aka boner yeah that was his nickname
in this 80s sitcom now growing pains was
a reference point on the episode evan
peters first appeared in
and one division director matt shakman
got his showbiz start as a child actor
on just the 10 of us which was a growing
pain spin-off so the guy's got boners on
the brain now monica reads this from an
overdue
water bill now look closely and the
charges go
way up in the month of october maybe
because that's when the heck
started and ralph maybe needed to
hydrate a lot more after his high speed
halloween hijinks or this is also when
agatha moved in and we know she loves
gardening all those purple flowers using
a lot of hose water
i don't know they might still be the one
ever bloom after all especially that's
not dead she's gonna be growing stuff in
that town
can't wait to revisit catherine hunt now
she also gets this from the name on his
headshot meaning ralph is an aspiring
actor i actually assume they used one of
evan peter's real early head shots
i love it now the fact that water bills
overdue an aspiring actor living in west
view new jersey in that house
uh-uh the guy's broke ralph is not jimmy
wu's missing witness folks this isn't
like a casting assignment that's not
what they do for people federal witness
protection they don't give them head
shots with their names on it they know
what their own face looks like he's just
an actor and people in federal witness
protection are forbidden from any
attention-grabbing behavior like going
anywhere you might appear on the news
or attempting to break an acting career
that plus his water bill goes back
several months and jimmy said his
witness moved there recently
and jimmy saw pietro on screen and
didn't say anything so stop asking me if
ralph is a federal witness protection
person he's not but
but he's not but then billy future
wiccan uses his telepathy to sense his
parents interestingly
he sees wanda using her chaos magic to
choke the townspeople
before she actually does that in the
following scene that means billy can
see the future like raven wanda pleads
her case
you're fine you're fine i've kept you
safe in here you feel at peace
doesn't this sound like the kind of
rationale other mcu villains use like
loki saying
is this not simpler or thanos expecting
the universe to be grateful
they all mean well but as agatha
correctly points out
heroes don't torture people no who does
villains
she's gonna be a villain now one who
tries to be merciful by opening the hex
walls which with this red color does
kind of evoke the parting of the red sea
by moses
which would let the hebrew slaves flee
to freedom but also let's end
the cruel pharaoh this case hayward as
the town glitches the movie theatre
marquis
toggles between ones we've discussed big
red and kidnapped the way these people
are kidnapped in a big red hex also
visionate big red gum
ah is the green powerful and this modern
one tan hauser gate which is an odd to
the tears of rain monologue in blade
runner this episode also deals with the
philosophy of ai and metaphysics like
blade runner did and then put the fun
and dysfunction
seems to be a fictional title like you
can see a yellow poster for this movie
in the post credit scene looks like a
rom-com maybe a kid's movie
but the theater name is the coronet
theater hornet is a small
crown reflecting the scarlet witch crown
at the center of wanda's identity and
agatha's envy
also during this glitching you can
briefly see a billboard flipping to an
ad for hydra
soak the soap commercial from episode
three just like how we saw logos paper
towels last episode and with the hex now
open
vision billy and tommy begin to
disintegrate and their particles are
these
tetrisy jigsaw blocks like the walls of
wanda's house as she constructed it last
episode both anna to joe quezada's
amazing house of m cover art that i've
referenced like a million times and the
family lines up like the incredibles
referenced back in episode six
wanda protects them with a spherical
shield just like violet does for her
family
now in the library is this banner
reading the library is a place to be
with beehive hexagons which i only bring
up because clearly agent franklin's
beekeeper form had to mean something
another loose end that we will address
an inside marvel stay tuned and then
vision cleverly tricks white vision with
a logical paradox
i request elaboration i'm gonna use a
[ __ ] out of that so vision brings up the
ship of theseus from greek philosophy
how much can you replace the pieces of
something
until its identity has now changed with
white vision stuck in a paradox
both are the true ship and neither are
the true ship this is kind of the way
they try to defeat robot santa with a
logical paradox of futurama consider
this
you are programmed to destroy the
naughty but many of those you destroy
are in fact
nice i submit to you that you are
naughty
and that logically you must destroy
yourself
unfortunately for white vision his head
wasn't built with paradox absorbing
crumple zones so
vision offers a solution to the paradox
perhaps
the rot is the memories the wear and
tear of the voyages
the wood touched by theseus himself so
vision is saying memory determines
identity the soul
that's a big reason why it's so
meaningful later when wanda finally
justifies vision's existence
as an extension of her soul and he
echoes this same concept
i have been a voice with body a body but
not human and now
a memory made real vision restores the
memories from the data
inside white vision showing us lots of
mcu flashbacks first panel showing
characters in the moments from age of
ultron iron man hulk the hulkbuster
armor paul and joannisberg and
avengers tower wanda walking out of the
door in sokovia also vision's birth and
avengers tower then shuri scanning his
head infinity war the moment he grabbed
ultron's head which is kind of what this
moment with white vision is paralleling
the gold
versus the blue color tones gold
representing the jarvis voiced vision
blue representing a soulless ai
then when he wielded mjolnir and fought
centuries in that sokovian church
wanda fighting him to save hawkeye in
civil war his
two deaths at the hands of wanda and
then thanos and wakanda and infinity war
a shot of him firing that beam that hit
roadie in the civil war airport battle
you can actually see giant scott behind
him there
wanda flirting with him in avengers
compound vision helping her up after
that airport battle wanda cupping his
face in scotland an infinity war then
wanda trying to heal
corvus glade's wound right after that
and then thanos getting that mind stone
turning him into the corpse that later
ended up in swords hands
with these memories restored white
vision declares himself vision and
blasts
the hell knows where maybe a new
protocol to reassemble the avengers
maybe the apple store to
[ __ ] an ipod i don't know we're going to
talk more about white vision's future in
tomorrow's q
a wanda teasingly vanishes in front of
agatha
signaling to us that she has been
picking up some of agatha's moves
and has another learned tactic upper
sleeve the boys
handle the military love that line with
tommy stealing a hat the way quicksilver
stole a hat as a speedster in the x-men
films hayward
shoots children though it looks like
that first shot would have gone between
them
hayward poorly shoots at children but
monica heroically jumps in front to take
the bullets she doesn't know these kids
have superpowers like she does
so that's nice of her now this time her
eyes glow yellow
each time her eyes kind of glow a
different color reflecting whatever
radiation she's connected with in that
moment perhaps here maybe it's the
gunfire or the metal of the bullets but
either way the bullets refract through
her and then slow and then drop
out the other side it's just another
example of monica's abilities as
spectrum or photon whatever name they're
gonna go with absorbing all forms of
energy
and sort of redirecting it or reapplying
it but interesting
notice her eyes follow a bullet as it
whizzes past her a sign that she
also must be capable of moving at super
speeds which is also something spectrum
can do in the comics and then i love it
darcy rams hayward in that funnel cake
truck which remember
that warped from an armored truck in
episode six it actually warps back to
that later and remember warped materials
retain their composition explaining why
she could ram hayward like this
wanda sneaky sneaks up to agatha to
curse her the same quick movement that
she did to the avengers and age of
ultron in this case agatha's nightmare
is the painful memory of her witch trial
seeing her coven resurrect might have
been why she was so fearful of wanda
being able to raise the dead but then
the coven turns on wanda the scarlet
witch recognizing her as the foretold
harbinger of chaos with her red crown
forming her head
linking it to the blue crown that formed
on evanora's head but wanda ends up
breaking out of this using agatha's envy
for
the chaos magic against her feeding her
more of it and more of it while luring
her into a trap
of runes that disable her magic just
like the ones agatha used to trap wanda
and i love the moment agatha tries to
use her magic but nothing happens just
like thanos and endgame
i am inevitable
so wanda absorbs agatha's magic and
becomes the full scarlet witch
amazing costume with this nice m shape
in the crown
like one of the runes down in the
basement maybe hinting at a future house
of m
event in multiverse of madness with this
m shape in her crown
and this other interesting runic shape
on her belt buckle i'm wondering
if both of these could be some sort of
protective runes that protect wanda the
scarlet witch wherever she goes
very cool design now some are comparing
wanda's wardrobe to magneto michael
fassbender's look but i really love how
it incorporates the colors of all the
magic she now possesses
the way agaves purple and blue dress did
here wanda's red and act this purple mix
to form this dark dark scarlet and then
you can see little stripes of blue on
the legs
she's got the power of herself of the
mind stone of agatha and of the other
members of that coven and wanda
now if you listen has a bit more of a
cicopian accent comeback decides to
imprison agava as a
nosy neighbor agnes in westview i'm
sorry
no you're not you're cruel you have no
idea what you've unleashed
indeed a dark move by wanda to trap
agatha in this dollhouse routine and
when agatha turns into agnes notice she
retains the brooch no matter what that
stays with her
but now it's kind of a way wanda can
identify her almost like a scarlet
letter and then the two part with
i'll be seeing you agnes now if i see
you first time
if i see you first sounds like a veiled
threat agatha may come back to haunt
wanda before wanda expects it and then
wanda envisioned tuck and the boys
saying
family is forever and wanda
interestingly says this
boys thanks for choosing me to be your
mom
ah another sign that these boys might
have come from a source
outside of wanda's magic she didn't
conceive and give birth to them
they chose her it's kind of like a
rescue dog who rescued who right and
then wanda and vision hold hands as the
hex closes in
reflecting that famous closing shot of
fight club as the narrator and marlar
hold hands watching their world collapse
around them but then wanda says this
beautiful monologue
you vision are the piece
of the mind stone that lives in me
you are a body of wires and
blood and bone that i created
you are my sadness and my hope
but mostly you're my love and like we do
division cries a single tear
matching that panel in avengers 58 and
they promised to find each other again
maybe wanda's future in the multiverse
could result in a vision from an
alternate reality merging with white
vision similar to the insanity that
restores vision in the comics but right
now we're getting ahead of ourselves
this is about letting go
not figuring out when we're gonna find
each other again and as we cut from
wanda's hex to reality you may notice
her right hand starts being higher
and then suddenly her left hand is
higher on the other side of the cut but
i don't think that's a mistake because a
real detail here emotional trigger
warning her wedding band
and her engagement ring are also now
missing from her left hand so the last
thing this fading hex did was
lift the rings off her finger
essentially reversing the moment wanda
magically
married them back in episode one so now
wanda finds herself back in the empty
lot as if nothing has happened
dorothy waking up from the dream this
was foreshadowed by young wanda in that
flashback last episode
by the end of the episode you realize
it was all a bad dream but the people of
westby will never forget
way to ruin it for all mutants wand up
and these people are going to be so mean
to the mutants but monica at least
wishes her well
bye wanda
[Applause]
good luck good luck does take wanda back
to that simple probability hex that she
could cast as a kid
back when bringing herself good luck was
as magical as it got for her but my oh
my how this witch has grown post credit
scene number one
the scroll searches back on this scroll
is an associate of nick fury an
old friend of maria and monica rambo
from the days of captain marvel
setting up monica to join fury on that
scroll space station that we see him on
in the far from home post credits scene
which is again seven months after this
now by the way i'm thinking this is not
taylor's daughter because monica
probably would have recognized her and
be like hey buddy nice eyes but they
revealed this scroll transformation
directly in the lens flare of that
projector light kind of a weird shot
setup right i'm thinking maybe it's
another visual setting up monica's
future as photon or spectrum which both
names come from the fact that she has an
electromagnetic physiology but the final
final
scene picks up with wanda in a cabin by
this mountain lake we got a couple
options for where this could be this
could be just her home country of
sokovia some are saying it could be
alkali lake
the location of the weapon x lab that
created wolverine or it could be
wundergore mountain the location of the
citadel of the high evolutionary
where magda gave birth to wanda and
pietro in the comics bova showed up in
episode two remember
bova's the bovine nursemaid created by
the high evolutionary if this
is wundergore that tea wanda bruise
could be that wounded war ever bloom
herb i theorized agave was brewing for
her in episode 7. there's something
weird going on here
wanda freaking bare hands the metal
handle of a tea kettle that was just
boiling guess the girl likes it hot
now what's going on here wanda is using
astral projection
into her scarlet witch form to examine
the dark hole kind of like the way
doctor strange used astral projection to
study sorcery while he was sleeping but
the fact that
wanda is doing it while awake is
troubling because
how is she splitting her consciousness
like this everyone else does it when
they're either incapacitated or sleeping
wanda seems to be pulling alternate
versions of herself already from
alternate realities to be able to do
this but listen to the music here
this is michael g aquino's doctor
strange theme
[Music]
and chiquino composed the opening marvel
studios title card theme
this version of it actually first
appeared in the dr strange movie in 2016
so in a way jk news music has been here
with us in one division
the whole time but in the final seconds
from the dark hold
wanda hears the voices of billy and
tommy calling for help
as wanda's eyes widen with recognition
we flash
to red what's going on here well how do
we get here
remember the camera swooped in from an
insane
distance and without cutting it glides
all the way into the back interior room
very eerie very evil
dead sam raimi it's like we are a
disembodied spirit a fellow astral
projection
watching wanda maybe dr strange the
sorcerer supreme whose powers wanda has
apparently surpassed
and the avengers she will probably be a
villain too in multiverse of madness
i think wanda is recreating what we saw
in the dark hold pages the wavy-haired
sorceress creating these circle hexes
doing what channeling her nexus powers
to tap into the multiverse
to find an alternate reality like the
one she created where she can go on to
be with vision and her sons
but the problem is those boys came from
some mystery outside source
and now that their voices are screaming
out for help it makes us wonder what
darker threat this scarlet witch
unleashed to use the word of agatha's
warning look there's all kinds of
demonic forces out there
we're gonna meet at least one of them in
multiverse of madness i win the other
video while i'm still on that crazy
mephisto train
obviously not for the nine episodes of
wanda vision he was a total no show
hundreds of you have been very kind to
remind me of that on twitter thanks but
hey now that marvel has set the stage
for satanic witchcraft and the darkhold
there's always a future marvel title
loki multiverse of madness
just saying if those demon spawn are
still in the mix the devil is still in
the details but hey to be honest i don't
really care about that right now i'm
just in full appreciation for this
series with its creepy funny
heartbreaking mysterious
nonsense and being able to theorize
about it week to week with you
all so thank you so much for sticking
with me and knowing that new rockstars
is always aimed for more than just like
theory accuracy like if you were with us
before wandavision you know that all too
well
and if you found us through one division
welcome the madness is just beginning
and thanks again to conflict of nations
for sponsoring this video conflict of
nations is the free online pvp strategy
game happening
in a modern global warfare you get an
exclusive gift
click on the link in the description to
get this exclusive gift of 13
000 gold and 1 month of free premium
subscription offer only available for 30
days don't lose time click on the link
in the description choose your country
and fight your way to victory
and another reminder to check out our
unusual couples shirt which is still
available but selling out fast
because a new latest obsession
collectible will be announced soon
get it at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for
everything marvel thanks for watching
boners
[Music]
you
[Music]